the story the i-team first broke accused
child killer tyrell rhodes grabs a
detective's
loaded gun and the i-team has obtained
video of what could have turned into a
deadly situation
the i-team's vanessa murphy joins us
live in studio with how it all unfolded
vanessa
a metro homicide detective testified
terrell rhodes had just confessed
to killing two-year-old amari nicholson
he faces a murder charge and now
additional charges including attempted
murder
for what you're about to see
so you can see there one of rhode's
hands was in cuffs
he was agitated detectives seemingly
tried to get him to calm down
he reached over and grabbed the gun from
homicide detective opal deeds holster
a struggle ensues to get the loaded gun
back from him
metro police say rhodes had just
admitted to beating omaree to death and
he drew this
map for them to show where he put
amari's remains
near paradise and twain his body was
found
the next day now i reached out to metro
for a comment on that incident with the
gun i'm waiting to hear back
i also reached out to the police union
and union head steve grammes sent me a
statement which
reads in part that the officers moved
swiftly and controlled the suspect's
movements
to disarm him we'll put the full now
statement at
back to you